过去一年只要我出门就会带这一小包华装品
因为他们每一个都很迷你
但是又很实用
基本上能够满足我在旅游出差时换一个完整的权装
首先就是这个发展大的话装包
真的是非常非常小
就给手机要宽一点
还没有的一个恋大
看起来平清洗
但是它里面是自带发光的小镜子的
而且还有冷暖、自然、三种光源
但我们平时在飞机上或者高铁上化装
又怕光线不好
那有它就是很方便的
而且它看起来小小的
但是很能装
我这么多块都挺全部都能装进去
接下来这是一个迷迷的分辨
这个是
这他们价的
你们一定要是我今天的底装
就是用它画的非常的完美
你带它出门就不需要再带什么
夜体粉底和散粉了
它就相当于是粉底加散粉二合一
这么小小的一个
它居然还自带一个粉铺
但是我觉得它用双拉子上装更自然
不需要什么手法
你就穿穿两下盲脸上对就行了
三十秒钟就是一个完美的底装
而且它的装感是真的很好看
只有假铃会逼搬的粉铃要强一些
脸上都应用它点个两次
就能折个七八成
但是装感又很轻透
特别适合在外面旅游
被感时间
你的底装用它随便了
就搞完了
这个我就爱它
爱到什么地方
我还买了一个大的
我在家里面用着
这种就带出门用
如果是超级大游屏姐
没在比意额头这种容易出油的地方
可以
再用这个
这个小白病
在局部的另一个装
它是它们家的大白病的米米
我就将它小白病了
它的粉质也是非常非常的吸引的一种
而且控油力超长在这个夏天
油皮姐妹一定会用得到它
这就是这个了
你们知道它是什么吗
它计视一个要是扣也是一个纯密
就会一个硬幣差不多大
可以拿它当包华
非常可爱
它打开里面会有个防臣
该所以是很温深的
它里面是这种
这里的制定
我的这个色号选的是
非常的清透
但是有很提气色
再来呢
就是一套化妆说完了
跟我今天的衣服好搭呀
去年我是给你们分享
这个米米刷子
它里面大部分都是页部的刷子
今年我找到了一套
可以涵蓋我们所有全妆的
米米刷
顏值非常的高
而且也顺平价
塞红三份修容高光
眼影折下鼻影
它全部都有
而且它的这个刷毛这个巨软
我刚刚那个粉并
就是用它上的
无论你出去是
日常通行
还是说要出习商务的场合
要换个全妆
它全部都可以帮你搞定
而且用了它
我出门
再也不用担心我的
说要怎么装了
我之前都是哪一个保鲜带
然后把我的化妆刷
全部放进去
但是一点的不好放刷赶
很长
而且搞得一起
很容易弄髮
但是有了它的化就
一点都不用担心
哦
这个是我的真爱塞红
一定要分享给你们
它已经是一个战损版了
我买了他们家的正妆
然后这个是他们家的Mini Sites
特别的小
但是它里面是自带塞红刷
和一个小镜子的
而且还有一个格末
可以把刷刷刷塞红分开
就是很卫生
它是这种
带有一点点光则改的
密桃色
我今天的脸上就是用了它
完全不调人
不调皮也不调装
怎么刷你的
不会刷上后屁股
只有想的话
其实我也设满多的
但是我觉得最适合
带出门的
还是我去年
就给你们分享过的
这个Mini的三色
这小盘
三种颜色
黑眼圈都印下
此都可以用它折住
而且它
八的很老
但是它的粉质
也很吸引你
这一部分就是它的调色盘
你可以调出自己想要的颜色
而且它是可以反复用的
就是这个严用一次之后
你还可以你们来
该也会去
然后下一次你在打开
这个我能用个
十加十次都是没有问题的
这个是我非常喜欢的个点影
它就是用起来很方便
你就拿手
随便在眼里上图一下就OK了
不需要什么化妆
尽巧你图云就行了
它出来就是一个暖密桃色的
很漂亮的眼妆
这个就是我这种
瘦殘桃能用的眼影
你们肯定也能用
老头的话
就可以把它当作你的一个打底色
这个变写式的节毛夹
它比我用过任何一个
当体节毛夹都要好用
小小一个
不管你的节毛有多硬
它轻轻松松就可以
给你夹出一个太阳花了
这个我不只是在外面
用我在家里面也收了它
用这个
在家上我这个推进过
无数次的节毛打底
你的眼睛真的就是
可以一下子边的很有神
而且这个节毛打底
它不云
就是我是那种用什么
节毛高冬云的人
这个我不云
没比我带的是这个
它非常的细
它比一只比还要细
我喜欢它的点
就是它的这个头
就和你写字的比一样细
所以你用它去画眉毛
它可以非常轻松的
就给你画出那种
跟分明的眉毛
而且它后面还配了一个刷子
这个刷毛也是
非常非常的软的
这个也只要九块九
分享给大家
所以后再给你们看一下
我们是怎么把他们撞回去的
真的很轮撞